Okay, so at the outside
I'm not necessarily responding to this person
or this comment.
I typically don't
for two reasons. One,
the vast majority of Americans support abortion access.
I don't need to convert anybody,
so it's just generally not worth my time.
2. It's also not worth my time to
engage with these male like,
thoughtless
allegations that aren't grounded in either policy
or women's experiences
and are basically just an attempt to shame women for
what is largely men's irresponsible ejaculations.
I did come on here to say though,
but it always dumbfounds me how like
men across the world
commit approximately 80% of all violent crime.
Depending on the location of the type of crime,
that number can be a lot higher.
So for example,
in the United States,
98% of all mass shooters are men.
So for starters,
it seems likely that if men could get pregnant
that they literally would have abortions for fun.
Like they accuse women of doing that
even though there's no research to support it.
Um, but like,
they kill alive
independent people for fun.
Like a lot women
pregnant women.
So despite that reality
and the fact that zero of them have
any first hand experience with abortion,
none of them have ever needed one,
they still think
that they get to label what an abortion is and is not.
It's such a sad, pathetic.
And ability to decenter yourself
and acknowledge that you like
obviously as a fact
don't Know what you're talking about